five one and his Matt I would sit in
sand a little bit today so I talked
about desk task is a library for
parallel computing in Python I've gotten
a lot of talks about tasks in the last
few months and I'm trying to give new
content and every talk so this will be a
little bit of overview of you and in a
particular topic within tasks so be very
different content from the tutorials if
you're here on Friday so as an overview
dass provides is Allegra pearl computing
it was originally designed to paralyze
the libraries like numpy and pandas to
sort of core libraries within our
ecosystem however we found is that the
system that we built in order paralyzed
these libraries was useful for other
arbitrary computations as well systems
that weren't just big arrays big data
frames and that has ended up being
surprisingly as useful or maybe even
more useful of an application so let's
uh should be slightly refreshed these
talks are online and as you'll notice
there's an OE link so they said again a
few talks recently so if one more
overview talk you can go to the site pie
talk here that was given in 2012 and
2016 we're talking PI Gotham's more
about data frames and this talk will be
more about fine-grained task scheduling
so we're technically how do we schedule
sort of more arbitrary computations so
some of the technical some of the
overview hopefully is something for
everyone so in the beginning there was
none pi and it was good except if your
dad it was large in the ran or if you
wanted to use more than one CPU numpy
looks kind of like this there are you
know an N dimensional array and there's
a bunch of functions that efficiently
keep you on that array and reduce some
other n dimensional array dasker a was
the first project came out of desk and
we created one large and dimensional
array out of many small non pirates
mislead us whose mo mini course it also
let us scale out to disk it also let us
work on a distributed cluster so n
dimension larae our algorithms are hard
there's a lot of interesting algorithms
in there that are sort of more
sophisticated
than typical you know database kinds of
algorithms and so this would required a
lot of coordination so das became very
very good at coordinating parallel
algorithms after we had das gray going
fairly well the obvious thing to do was
to paralyze pandas and so with the help
of law dependent developers we made a
stout a-frame and similarly das ladder
frame is one logical large data frame
composed of many small pandas data
frames so it's pandas under the hood and
we're just calling a different plan
dysfunctions every time this could end
run on you know on your laptop using all
your cores scanning out your disk or on
a cluster so let's see how we're gonna
cluster there's usually the fun part
that's actually pretty good resolution
so am i right we're seeing the status of
the cluster and the left I have a sort
of standard Jupiter notebook now what I
have here is I have six CSV files that
have the first half of the 2015 New York
City Taxi Cab data set so there's all
the cab rides in the city of New York
for 15 think January to June reading
from HDFS and it's has broken up our six
CSV files into 91 different blocks of
bytes so these green bits is the report
of one core on my 24 core cluster
pulling off some but them some bites
from HDFS and after that there's a call
to pandas read CSV to turn those bytes
into a panda's data frame so well it's
just it is this on these 24 different
processes on you know three notes
it created 91 different panas data
frames that are currently sitting in
memory on those three computers now this
one object this - data frame which is
coordinating all those little pandas
data frames that looks you know just
like panda's data frame and it satisfies
the subset of the api so there's some
nice you know data here we've got all
the rides that happened when someone was
picked up when they were dropped off how
many passengers there were they all
break down of the fare well the tip was
etc
and we have to load this data into you
know it's not that big it's 28 gigs but
it'd be uncomfortable on my math but it
feels very comfortable here on this
cluster so if I do an operation on this
data frame let's let's say little
compute the length of the data frame how
we're gonna do that so on this right
side we're seeing all the competitions
all the cores have done over time so for
example you know this particular core
spent 700 microseconds computing the
length of one of the data frames so we
could do lengths with all the
intermediate data frames we communicated
all those data frames to one machine all
those lengths to one machine and we then
summed that up and in total that took
something like you know let's you know
tens hundreds of microsecond of
milliseconds so we got a patio a nice
response and nice human interactive time
so that's how to ask works tasks
coordinates many Python calls on many
different computers and coordinates them
together so does like da Steiner frame
use that on you know to reduce down
different computations computing the
length of a table frame is an optically
hard let's do something more complex
let's see how well New Yorkers tip so
we're makin death routes and bad rows in
this line we're then gonna make a new
column which is the tip fraction so was
it a 20% tip for this ride or a 10% tip
for this ride they're gonna group by the
hour of the day so using some nice you
know pandas daytime functionality if
people are familiar with pandas this
should look familiar to you
and we'll just ask the cluster compute
that for us and it does not doing lots
of different group buys offering
publications it sort of combines as a
result there's other more group buys
lots of fun things you got this nice
results in about three seconds of
computation that New Yorkers tip
extraordinarily well at 4:00 a.m. like
really well it's it's it's 38% here on
average
so you know we're getting some nice data
science out of interesting data set at
scale this is a very small cluster a
very small problem but this scales up
quite nicely especially this does that
come VI yes this is if your app
installed tasks and distributed you
didn't port ask you start something up
so a question the question is I'm review
preference just for the video next
question is does it need to work on a
cluster does work on a machine it works
just fine in a single machine actually
for the first year of desks life it was
just on a single machine so we found
that most people had problems in the
sort of like 10 200 gigabyte range they
were very well served with you know
their laptop or even just a big
workstation even like this problem is
way faster on a workstation than on a
cluster you can get this down way faster
on the big heavy machine so yeah tasks
scales down very nicely it's pure Python
easy to install I'll talk about some of
these topics as well in future so that's
a big data frame and you know a lot of
people that is really what's very useful
however many problems don't fit into a
big array or a big data frame such a lot
of problems that when you're first
started this who will come to us said ok
we have this interesting problem ok
great I've got this big data frame how
do I shove my problem into a big data
frame and that shoving process was
awkward we're trying to rewrite a lot of
code and it wasn't very natural
fortunately the system that we built to
build a screen data frame task just
asked the core we found that was still
very applicable in these cases and so in
many cases someone had Python code and
we could paralyze it well using just ask
so again task is not passed out of him
DAF data frames module built on top of
desk and ask is a general tool for
paralyzing and computations so here's a
script of code I'm gonna walk through
there's some parallelism here there's a
lot of for loops in this comprehensions
we're going to walk through it see what
it looks like and get a sort of
intuition for computations that we can
paralyze that are not data frames
they're not you know maps and filters of
group bys there are more cost
so we're starting out we're gonna load a
bunch of repulsive load function a lot
of file names and here I'm gonna
represent these computations so circles
are little functions and data boxes are
results we've got you know 10 file name
it's gonna called load in all of them so
this is obviously parallelizable I will
load in some special data set some
reference data set maybe from some
sequel database and that's it's a
different computation but it'd still be
run in parallel it's still present here
they don't want to normalize all my
pieces of data against that special
piece of data that that normal reference
database it's not that normal reference
data set so here this is not quite a map
it's something slightly more complex but
it's still really a lot of parallelism
here maybe each of these results is for
one day of data and I want to maybe take
every third day and you know and do some
sort of rolling computation so here I'm
taking every third data set I'm doing
some sort of rolling computation and
down here you can see some normal Python
code that sort of effects that that
computation here running with Python and
this is actually how you can use tasks
as well to do the same things so of all
the outputs we're gonna want to consider
all pairs and you can compare them in
some way but that's too many things for
just take a random subset of 20 these
are all operations I sort of see people
using commonly in the wild here's just
rabbit way toward problem but these are
sort of some things are representative
of maybe some things that you do that
will find the best one do some sort of
reduction so that computation actually
hop over here so I'm gonna sort of mock
out some simple Python functions for all
the functions we just saw and then using
this project delayed which is described
well in a previous talk we can just sort
of take that function and wherever I
call that function don't actually call
it locally here but instead add it as
some lazy value to some task graph and
so we're sort of marking this function
is something you should do later they're
going to run this same code that we have
that we just went through and let's go
ahead and visualize it looks like sewed
asked built up that graph for us of
parallel computations
we don't want to we can now connect back
to our cluster and ask our cluster
compute that computation for us so we
had the sort of arbitrary graph and
dowsing able to compute that arbitrary
got for us in parallel at sort of a
small computation for this cluster so
let's increase some numbers at a hundred
files take a thousand samples justice or
to be a bit more flashy so you're seeing
here is - cos is working on our
computation well it's being fairly
responsive and its operating on on
custom computations
I think I'm gonna stand up for a bit to
see a bit more engaging okay so this
flexibility is useful we can we can
write parallel code in a way that is
actually fairly similar to how we write
normal code
it also lets us do more complex
algorithms which is which is pleasant
it's also tricky to do well I love this
talk about how would history can do well
in how we sort of tried to overcome that
challenge at a technical level so
normally when we solve these problems we
use some high level parallelism project
something like spark or a sequel
database or some distributed array
library these always sort of ask us to
rewrite our computations in some small
set of operations so in SPARC this is
map filter group by joining etc and
sequel it's a sequel language or a
linear algebra really something like
spark all spark operations roughly fall
into three categories
there's map partitions so it has
embarrassingly parallel like map or
filter there is shuffle an alt all kind
of communication something like group by
or join or there's aggregations
something like min or max are distinct
and spark has has Optima is the heck out
of these three optimizations these three
operations because everything is based
on those if you build these three things
you get a sort of database like project
but as you've seen sort of some projects
some problems don't fit into this model
sort of show a few so here's our custom
pipeline problem from before so ETL
problems are fairly well represented
here
so there's projects that do this systems
like Luigi so this picture of sort of an
interesting graph is on Luigi's front
page some of those things like airflow
in this picture of an interesting graph
or on air flows front front page these
are two libraries that are used for this
sort of common data engineering tasks as
other things too so if you want to do
efficient time series computations so
here I've got a data set that's a
partitioned by month so all my pen
without a frames I've got a data frame
for January data frame for from March
but I want to do something on a weekly
basis so we need to sort of take a
sliver of data from one and sort of
share it across to the other sort of
nearest neighbor computation that's
something that's that's hard to do with
map shuffle reduce this Oh dad or him
can do all these things and I show you
a rolling operation said it's the same
sort of seems for to deal and
dimensional array operations are
actually quite interesting so here I'm
creating a two dimensional array
I'm taking the sum along some axis and
I'll take so this is actually doable
with with map and I create what upon us
say take the transpose add it to itself
this computation sort of is now tricky
this is a bit this is not like a
standard computation if you're sort of
these graphs are fun to look at you
don't you to understand what they do but
they should get the impression that they
are they're sort of fun and sort of
strange and so it's the Challenger is
computing these strange graphs here's a
matrix multiply on top of the transpose
and we can sort of keep composing these
things to make them more and more
complex this is actually fairly mundane
this is fairly simple
so there's also modern algorithms so if
you want to do is sort of an efficient
numerically stable SVD here's a
competition that does it released in
paper a couple years ago that was
written into - by the author and it's
it's you know non-trivial you want to do
with an approximate algorithm as well I
guess the little little scarier so these
is sort of arbitrary graph execution is
a new thing sort of and it does two
major values that eases developer burden
it's much easier to write algorithmic
code it's so much easier to sort of
translate your sequential code in dog
and the code into parallel code it also
allows you to use more sophisticated
algorithms allows you to tackle more
custom applications again it's sort of
hard to do well so arbitrary graph
scaling is hard masculine it's hard for
a simple if I had this graph and I had
this cluster of computers which
computations this graph - I sent to
which computers and when do I
communicate the results from one
computer to another and when do I
release data those are all questions
that are hard hard to answer
in fact it's known if you optimally
doing this if you know all of the
information is NP hard which computer
science below this will know it's a
synonym for very very very hard and then
doing this so this is the same
competition on a slightly less trivial
problem doing this scalably so these
graphs often end up being hundreds of
thousands of nodes large
doing the scalable e requires that we do
it in linear time which beat ISOs no
means you know not too slow
so fortunately we can do pretty well
with heuristics and sewed ask is the
sort of core task scheduler of desk is a
collection of ease heuristics that works
pretty well
and all the problems that we've thrown
it so far so array problems out our
frame problems machine learning problems
etc task is a dynamic task scheduler for
custom arbitrary computations it works
well on testing machines run clusters at
us around a 200 micro second per task
overhead used to MPI this is a very long
time
fuse most other things is this is pretty
fast we can process around 5,000 tasks
per second just an overhead handles how
the colony resilience etc on top of
tasks we built things like task grey for
none PI compiler for an impact pad
ability - that iframe for pandas and
such there's some collaboration with
machine learning folks other things
accessible in Python this is a little
bit small you see if I can I'm borrowing
a laptop today so yeah it's not going to
try you can pip install it you can
content install it you can actually read
the source code it's actually all pretty
understandable how much time to have
left that's great
all right so we use some mechanism to
create some graph that might be - data
frame that might be this sort of you
know arbitrary composition stuff we were
saying before and now our job is to
execute that graph in parallel so this
is a trace showing that computation
running on four threads on my local
machine this is a pipeline grid search
using scikit-learn computations now see
you know four little workers you know
traveling through this graph picking off
tasks running them completing them you
know sending that out to other workers
releasing the data when they can sort of
a trace is so they need to figure out
how to do well and this doing this well
strongly impacts our performance doing
this poorly causes everything to break
so nothing that I'm going to talk about
from here on now is anything you need to
think about this is just I want to
convey some understanding of how dynamic
task scheduling works and the sort of
things we think about so that when you
use desk
you sort of know what it's doing for you
that you never have to think about so
you can safely ignore the rest of this
talk
so vaskas discuss everything in the
small it has no idea what an array is or
what a data frame is or what a shuffle
is or reduction is it knows what a task
graph is and it takes a little part of
that pass graph and it figures out what
to do
all decisions are sort of done of that
sort of micro level but out of that if
we make the system just right we got
good macroscopic behaviour lost so also
all this is important cost and time
almost so here's a sort of a very simple
problem we have two computers we want to
compute this computation so we're
calling F twice on two inputs then we're
calling G on the result on their results
now we're calling F twice maybe F takes
a while you might want to call F on each
of our different computers we got two
new bleeders just the Sue's in parallel
now we got to move one of those results
to the other order to run it on Newton
order to run G should we do look at X
look at Y and see which one's smaller
want to move the smaller one in order to
reduce our network costs unless of
course maybe F is very fast and his
results are very large there might be
have to be faster run both FS on one
machine and not use parallelism at all
or maybe G has to run on a GPU and only
one of our machines has a GPU so there's
a lot of interesting constraints that
can come up here and we distort of think
about how to measure things real time
now to sort of compute this thing well
when we don't know a lot of information
ahead of time so task is dynamic I mean
that it learns on the fly so here's a
very simple graph which function do we
run first we have both FS are available
and which one do we run first so we
choose to run the left one first because
something depends on it it's sort of
under critical path we can't finish a
computation until everything's finished
its run the left one similarly in this
case which function should we run first
the left F for the right F so we should
run the one on the left again because
that will expose more parallelism once X
is in RAM we have lots of other choices
since we have more workers maybe we can
sort of flood those workers without your
tasks we can be more parallel in this
case we have two functions that depend
on different amounts of data
on first we run the one on the right
because that will allow us to free up
this data once it finishes so we can we
can free memory and release our
resources so there's a single system
task scheduler in the middle that does
all of this logic cornices logic it's
been very thoughtfully put a bottle of
water up here and there's a sort of a
fleet of workers that do whatever the
scheduler says the workers hold on to
the data and then communicate amongst
each other to share results but the
scheduler coordinates everything to a
very very good secretary though there's
one for clients us rejecting the
scheduler asking the cluster to do
things for us so once we've decided to
tasks we want to run let's say we have
two workers well send that task to some
will assign that task to some worker
it'll be sort of pending once that
worker is free will actually send the
information about that tasks about that
function over the worker the work will
start processing it in a local thread on
some other machine somewhere else once
it finishes it will hold on to that data
in that worker until someone needs that
data might be another worker that needs
some result that it just produced or
might be the client saying actually the
last function you just computed I want
that one you'll send it back to the
client now if we have some other
function f of X so function that depends
on the road what we just made where do
we run it you're not on the top machine
of the bottom machine so shoes around
the top machine readout locality we
don't want to move X around moving data
around is sometimes expensive especially
with large numbers arpenaz data frames
there any gigabytes large and your
network is slow so we process it you get
some results back similarly if you want
to compute on two variables x and y but
x and y live on different machines case
we got to choose one of the machines and
move one piece of data over the other
one which do we choose in this case
we're gonna choose but on the bottom
machine and then move down it over the
reason we do this is because why
probably takes up more bytes in RAM than
does X so we need to measure the number
of bytes that every piece of data in our
cluster takes up so we can
decisions well in a more you know common
situation you might have this case where
running at the F of x and y so we look
at our two workers you say x and y are
both on the top so no maybe one we want
we want to run on the top we also see
here that there's a lot of work pending
here on this top worker it seems you
pretty saturated so we may want is set
to move the data down to lower worker
this decision depends on a few things
it depends on the expected runtime of
all of the functions in the queue on the
worker it also depends on all the data
we'd have to move there's a calculation
we have to do there so you do a lot of
measurement in order to make this work
well similarly we might want to know a
new worker might come on we might want
to seal some work we need to sort of
find the right tasks to steal based on
the req spected run x was based on and
we have to move okay so intelligent
scheduling requires measurement and -
does a lot of measurement that is also
what gives us these nice visuals we saw
here on the right - is doing a very very
thorough job of measuring everything and
using that both in scheduling and in
visualization back to the user so you
can understand where your algorithm is
slow so we measure the number of bytes
using the size of protocol we measure
you know run times we ask the process in
case it has approvals I'm working well
we measure your network distance
everyone saw we heartbeat and we
actually see whether the time back was
we need lots of other things other
optimizations are not talking about at
all so we we can gracefully scale up and
down the cluster based on load we might
compress arrays or not sorry
so we might you know have a gigabyte
array we need to move and you decide if
we want to compress that or not we might
take you know 5 10 kilobytes samples
that array and try compressing them and
see if it's worthwhile or not then we
choose to do compress or not compress
something end up being very important
for a lot of rate computations then we
do for everything just because we can
there's lots of other optimizations that
show up if you want to compute many
small tasks we end up batching them if
you want to do many messages in a small
time we end up having batch them as well
you spelling is that it to disk all of
these optimizations
we're necessary to make tasks around a
scatter framework but none of them were
specific to arrays or data frames so
desk has no idea again what an array as
a data frame is so as a result all these
optimizations work everywhere including
on custom operation custom algorithms so
was a nice I was working with the second
layer developers a little while ago I
said hey I've got this computation I
need to move this particular piece of
data to all the workers because they're
all gonna need it and we won't do that
quickly you make all these functions
right just just try it out and see if it
works and just just worked and so even
on some more sobieski algorithms things
sort of just work a lot you need to
think about your comp your communication
as much so doing this well in Python was
was tricky so dowsing is a pure Python
library and these graphs can scale out
fairly large by routinely generate
graphs of sort of hundreds of thousands
you know a few million and we spend
around 200 microseconds per task total
overhead sort of we've got one task
throughout its entire lifetime so how
much it takes up in the scheduler it
takes about you know a kilobyte issue of
bytes and RAM in order to do this we
have to use just byte strings and core
Python data structures in Python which
are actually quite fast the core Python
data structures in Python are fast like
a Python dictionary is only you know
five times slower than the C++ ten
deliberate dictionary it's Python is
actually not bad at these things as a
result also the code is fairly
intelligible there's not a huge class
hierarchy if you know for loops and
dictionaries and sets and a couple of
the data structures you can actually
understand most of the policies that are
inside of tasks you can go right now
new github comm / - / distributed
scheduler you can see the policies you
can reason about them fairly easily it's
accessible to this community so people
often ask how does that compare with
spark they both seem to do big data
things and they do indeed both do big
data things so I am very biased right I
work on this thing I'm also very
ignorant so please you know ask someone
smarter than me if you actually want to
make the system intelligently so a few
differences first spark is firmly
established and asked is quite new and
then the obvious other obvious
difference is that task is written in
Python
and scholars written and/or spark is
written install so to large differences
if you like Python if you have Python
developers - might be something to look
at more focused technical differences
spark has largely focused on sequel like
or sequel plus computations in that sort
of map shuffle reduce paradigm tasks
because we've been focusing more on sort
of the pide out of space where there's
more intersting algorithms like an
emotional arrays machine learning
non-trivial machine learning we've had
to be a bit more open in general in our
execution strategy so one way to sort of
make this decision easily is if your
computation falls into the map shuffle
reduced paradigm SPARC is probably a
pretty good way to go it's pretty mature
yeah you won't get fired for choosing
spark however if your computation is a
bit more wacky that's my technical term
then tasks may may may be suitable
similarly that's can do some things
similar to air flow and Luigi and celery
sort of operates in the sort of low
latency generic tasks farming mode so
Basque is only better at computation
interactive computations or overheads or
lower our latency is lower because we
needed to really optimize for those
things and we think about the right way
to compress data which is not something
that most sort of ETL pipelines think
about you know inter worker
communication is a big thing however
Luigi and airflow and celery all have a
huge number of features that are really
used for people doing data engineering
workloads that just - doesn't have
because it can grow up inside of the
ecosystem we could build those there's
nothing fundamentally stopping us from
doing that you know tasks I I would
claim the task the core library the
scheduler is more sophisticated than
what you see in most other places but it
sort of hasn't had the same evolution in
this space for feature set the finer
airflow Luigi which is hugely valuable
right the feature inside of airflow and
Luigi save developers many many days of
time so that's it some final thoughts
so desk is a library for parallel
computing in Python you can do things
like parallel pandas and I select for a
large point of the room that's what is
most exciting about this talk that we
can do panda stuff on a cluster and it
seems to work pretty fast
but there's a sting beneath it which
ends up being very useful for a variety
of use cases both for suppose for
algorithm developers so academics doing
interesting things but also for
institutions that have a cluster bunch
of Python programmers I want to marry
the two I want to have sort of an easy
transition for those users so it sort of
like got this code I want to send a
bunch of it to the cluster I don't have
to think about rewriting stuff I just
want to activate this this cluster for
me that seems to be a fairly low barrier
to entry tool and it doesn't require a
whole lot of code rewriting will have
dived into a bunch of complex scheduling
stuff distributed dynamic task
scheduling as for more complex one
represented here but hopefully this
these from problems gave you an idea
there are things you think about when
building out written task scheduler
hopefully these give you a good idea of
sort of what sort of things you should
ask for from your disturbing computing
flat platform sort of how to reason
about what they're doing for you okay so
that's it quick acknowledgments so I
work on this I'm probably the loudest
task developer well there's countless
others both in the continuum and with
other open-source people also there's a
lot of buy-in from the sort of core PI
data type I developer community so the
data stream stuff was done with the
panas developers they're probably of the
past ten pull requests core panas
developers probably responsible for
eight of them you know the numpy
developers written task array second
learned developer is now pretty active
trying to figure out machine learning
things the joopa developers have been
very helpful in picking out all the
network stuff without a core buy-in from
the community which is encouraging
there's nice funding so I'm I'm page
work on this full-time which is nice you
should think continuing looks a little
bit
you should also thank the Exeter program
from DARPA and recently the Gorn Betty
Moore Foundation
their data driven data driven discovery
program and that's it
any questions thank you
please write the question is how old is
our scale with custom objects and what
should I do in order to make sure their
desk friendly so so the distributed
scheduler calls Python functions and
Python objects and a story so anything
is fine some things you should do to
maybe make things more nice you can omit
the sizer protocol if your data is
creating a lot of you're allocating a
lot of data the sizer protocols in the
implement that sort of tells python a
rough guess of your data footprint which
task would appreciate for scheduling
that's an easy thing to do it returns an
integer you should also make sure that
your things are easily serializable
to ask uses pickle or cloud pickle which
can do most things in practice people
don't care and they just use a naively
and everything works but if want to be
very nice I would appreciate letting the
size of particle ask your question in
the corner
yes the question generally is how do I
distribute my software on a cluster does
das help me there we're not so there's a
few different solutions
most people who used ask maturely and
large systems use something else like
docker or kubernetes to manage some of
that for them and that's what it
composes nicely with those systems there
are some hacks you can do within tasks
as well so dass is happy to distribute
egg files or python scripts out to all
the workers and make sure they're
running locally inside the path there's
a there's a way to distribute content
environments using tasks but I would say
for also for just dynamic code you write
in a notebook
that'll just be serialize nicely by clam
pickle so if you have a script or an egg
no problem if you have a bunch of
libraries you want to move around I
would suggest looking at something else
you know continuum has things they can
sell you docker is a great solution
other ways of managing NFS generally
managing suck software on cluster
something that - doesn't really want to
take on on its own
yeah so the question is how will does a
scandal a failed worker this was pretty
well so we have a full provenance of
everything that was needed to produce
that particular task we can rerun them
you also add workers dynamically
real-time so the whole system is
scalable clients can win and out workers
and going out
it's resilient its elastic just fine go
to the South room for a bit anyone over
here
right so how does ask handle
heterogeneity in my cluster I might have
you know many different racks that are
you know some communication is what is
cheap some is expensive
I might have machines with different
abilities so for communication all
workers are considered equivalent so
there's no rack to rack preference or
data center data center preference that
could be added it's not hard to do it's
you know it's all Python code to you
could if yours interesting to you they
can do it or you could pay me to do it
to people now pay money for open-source
stuff in tasks it's great for worker
heterogeneity
so there is a way to say these tasks
must run on workers with these
properties so this is common so the GPU
people were the ones really push this
originally I've got hundreds terminology
P use got this big graph these
particular tasks require machine that
runs on GPUs make sure that these two
sets are hooked up so that does that
that is fine
in parallel read it back at a later
point so the question is what is the
right binary format for desk data frames
yeah so if you're on a single machine I
would suggest hdf5 that's probably still
like the standard solution in a
distributed machine case ef5 doesn't
work well for a variety of reasons
unless it mostly doesn't work well for
righted reasons and you'd want to use
something like park' which is tends to
be pretty active in the hadoop space
there is no good Python pandas park'
solution at the moment to the West
McKinney's been working on a lot
recently I'm not sure how how pointed or
informed your question was this is
something that's in conversation right
now
there's not a very good binary format
for Python
honor Shiva to cluster there's active
work people have capital understand in
it
teen who's interested in it a lot of
four puppies are doing it the open
source world interests in it check back
in two months
mr. getting out us
does the workers so question is our
workers our cores on one machine aware
of each other and can they share data
cheaply or not yeah and so you can't you
can run so you can certainly run tasks
workers with a threat pool in which case
the workers will share memory and the
scheduler is aware of that
don't treat all those workers as being
sort of free to communicate amongst each
other so that's fine if you use
processes that's that's not available
it's refusing numeric code like numpy or
pandas or a second learn or cycling eyes
go to number eyes code the Gil is not a
problem threads are great and you should
be using threads that case you're
totally set I think the task worker if
you just like type in das worker you'll
get threats but there's a command line
there's failing interface that's very
easy to understand speaking of which
so there are two documentation pages one
Ford asked the sort of one Ford asked
the sort of parent project that has all
the algorithms like to ask that our
human task array the second dog page for
the distributed scheduler just on its
own this is all the information I've
just talked about about you know and
gentle into scheduling and the
documentation here will be more than
sufficient I believe to answer that
question
long installed on buster
yeah so question is I use number this
number work well with tasks in there
should be a context yes there was an
issue a long time ago that we fixed a
while ago yeah our during that time wait
okay yes the question is you know you
had a cluster but you also using a
laptop how did that work out so this
particular case I was using a jupiter
notebook that was hosted on the cluster
but you can use so the the scheduler the
so the scheduler and the workers need to
be close in the network but the clients
can be external so as long as the
software environment wean the clients
and the workers match everything is fine
because I have five minutes I just want
to switch to actually a small extra bit
of information slides if you guys are
patient enough so let's do
this is gonna be fun yes okay so uh huh
so here's the distributed scheduler
there are there's one scheduler there's
a client there's a couple of workers the
client offers a graph and sends that
graph up to the scheduler the scatter
looks like often finds that there's
three nodes that can run and it balanced
this is amok RAAS it's two workers a
worker finishes a couple of computations
and it reports back to the scheduler so
blue is finished here
horseback the scheduler hey these are
finished the scheduler then looks at
this extra tasks to run figures out who
should run it says oh both of these
pieces of data on this worker will send
that task up to this worker as well
thinking about data locality as we
discussed earlier the client learns
about this the client learns that these
computations have finished and it can
send up other computations real-time so
this isn't synchronous this is totally
asynchronous is there's a full
conversation happening on all things all
the time and let's have to learn about
that and schedule things appropriately
as a worker as the task is no longer
necessary the worker can garbage collect
the scheduler is aware of it and things
can be cleaned up to keep RAM RAM
friendly task is handles concurrent
workloads you can have multiple clients
operating on the same workers even with
the same data tasks is quite good at
providing uniquely identifiable names
and deterministic names on all
computations so if you if two people
were working on the same data set doing
the same computations they'll actually
be duplicated baskin load balance and
overtime there's you know this
conversation between workers and the
scheduler and the clients these
computations occur client can go away
and the scheduler can can remove that
computation workers can go away
and looks like this competition up here
at the top corresponding to this
computation here in the scheduler and so
we've lost that computation but it's
okay because we know how to recompute it
so it goes your point question earlier
about resiliency
so the distributing scheduler is one
system that coordinates all these
workers does that locality it's fully
asynchronous so much if you notice but
when I was playing with the notebooks we
submitted computations all the progress
bars going when we kept working in the
notebook doing other things so doesn't
block us
well it's user it's HDFS aware so it
handles flying with the sort of the
Hadoop world it also handles pretty well
with the non Hadoop world so we have
sort of people who use it from both
sides it's all these supports things
like the Osprey and data frame which
actually really good for early
benchmarking make sure that we had
support for these algorithms and it's
it's around 3,000 lines of tornado code
most of which is isolated to a certain
area
so let's write 3,000 times the total
code so trying to it's a it is a tornado
TCP application the tornado stuff has
been intentionally isolated from the
rest of the policy code so that non web
developers can reason about the code to
give an example of that
let's go look at how we decide workers
to use this is a bit of the logic that
we were discussing I will
so here's a function that takes in a
bunch of information about our task and
our dependencies and what everyone's
working on their jurisdiction areas of
strings because that's fast and it
determines with it within up you know 10
is 200 microseconds which worker to use
based on all that information and this
is code that you shouldn't get
immediately but it should not be
immediately scary to you issue something
that you should feel comfortable looking
at reasoning about and maybe hacking
with alright that's it I'm gonna finish
you off your time think I'll lunch is
coming up